[Applause]
nice what I want to know about let's
let's have a moment of truth between the
two of us
was that really bourbon did you really
just bang down all that bourbon I never
drink and tell be a mystery to the world
what's going through your mind you're
like I'm just gonna knock this down I
got this never dare a girl like me to do
anything I saw an Instagram you know two
different shoes but you you know you
have on the same don't you they're
different yeah I just couldn't make up
my mind this morning so I think you know
what I'm gonna wear one of each I love
that but you can do that I did it
Channing said the first thing he sees he
comes up to you says how many rap songs
are you in yeah that was my introduction
to Channing on his movie
yeah like hey I haven't even about your
rap life also how was it doing the
stunts and being the mind like ginger
ale the mind yeah she's the mind of this
at least right now and that was a good
challenge for you know a departure for
me to be like the cerebral character I
can't say I'm always chosen to be that
so it was it was a departure from what I
usually do
you're also a mixer what does that mean
sir what is what is what is a mixer mean
well I'm mixed
so I'm a classic mixer and you're gonna
find out what that means what does that
mean mixer where the stunts crazy the
stunts were really crazy in this movie I
mean I I haven't seen things like this
in a movie before Matthew Vaughn has
really pushed the envelope and gone
really far forward with some of the
things you see in this movie is there
gonna be a movie when you stop beating
people's behinds for a second like you
this is back-to-back movies where you're
beaten bucks
who says I'm beating butts in this
you'll be if you're in this movie did
you if you're in this movie you're
beaten but not necessarily necessarily
beaten but I mean ginger does the right
thing but not necessarily you need to
mix it right now and you want to mixer
I am the mixer I am the mixer go mix you
know ginger ale ginger ale that's it I
am without a little crazy when they said
ginger ale I loved it are you a ginger
ale drinker no I am NOT a ginger ale
drinker yes you do person this is what
happens when you drink a lot of bourbon
you know i comically silliness